[Background voices]
ANDY STERN >> Obviously people need a code
of ethics, but we need to appreciate that
right now there are four thousand companies
that have signed on to the U.N. guidelines;
every single major corporation has ethics
and values statements that their Board of
Directors sign. The signing statements is
not an indication of compliance. The rules
aren't self-regulating so to let corporate
executives off the hook by simply signing
a piece of paper is more about changing image
than changing reality. And only when they're
accountable, only when we deal with toxic
assets in the same way we deal with toxic
products which is prosecute people who abuse
their values and their authority will be we
be able to make the kind of changes we need.
So I totally believe in a code of ethics but
it has to be accountable, responsible and
enforced by everyone outside the corporation,
by governments and independent third parties.